hi there so here is the avatar this is
was knitted or crocheted crocheted or
whatever for me by galena
uh to thank me for my efforts in putting
up videos every day
as part of this whole project i must say
it's lovely i really like it
it's a tremendous sort of souvenir of
these 90 days
and
you'll notice i've changed my avatar
color
on link to yellow to match it
i'm very satisfied with what i achieved
during the 90 days if i look at my
statistics
here at link
i met my known words goal i acquired 10
000 new
more new words that the statistics show
that i know 10 000 more new words bear
in mind that in korean a lot of
essentially
words that have the same meaning have a
variety of different endings so if we
were to
just keep track of word families this
number would be much lower it doesn't
matter that's how we keep track of them
so i met my goal there i saved
9821 links that is words and phrases uh
my goal was only eleven hundred
so i've you know seven times more than
what i was obliged to do or eight times
more i did a lot of reading and a lot of
linking
uh links learned 779 versus a goal of
637
um
in fact i learned a lot more but i just
didn't bother going through and changing
the status i just wanted to make sure
that i pushed it over that 637 limit
hours of listening i just put in a
number of 133 hours in fact i probably
listened close to 200 hours because i
was listening at least two hours a day
just about every day so somewhere
between 150 and 200 hours of listening
words of reading that this would be an
accurate statistics statistic because i
did most of my reading at link and so
it's 78 000 words versus the goal of 63
000 words so in the last three months i
have read
the equivalent of a book in korean now i
also did read in some other books as
well textbooks and whatnot but the bulk
of my reading was here at link so
80 000 plus words read
words of writing that's where i fell
down
754 versus a goal of 3000 i regret that
i didn't do more writing in the end i
was pushed to it by my son mark i was
going to try to get out of doing it he
said i couldn't do that
if i had started writing earlier not
only would i have met my goal i think it
would have i would have done better
the writing helps me to express myself
it helps me to get a better grasp on the
writing system connect better with the
letters with this with the written
language
so i regret that next time i will write
more so that's something i learned
hours of speaking these are this is an
accurate measurement these are the
discussions i had linked with our tutors
13.3 hours
the goal was 12.7 so i
just exceeded the goal uh that's not a
lot over
three months that's like
call it four hours a little bit more
than four hours a month of online
conversation
uh
an hour a week uh 13 yeah i mean that's
all it is
um
you know it's my style different people
have different styles some people want
to get chatty uh earlier i want to build
up my vocabulary i want to get into
something interesting so i just end up
spending more time listening and reading
and less time talking
uh
again if if i know
with what i have achieved with the
number of words i've learned that if i
were to be in a situation where for
several evenings in a row
i was with korean people and we were
speaking korean that would activate a
lot of my passive vocabulary my passive
vocabulary my even in terms of you'll
see in the i'm you will see tomorrow a
video recording of a korean conversation
and you'll see that i stumbled with some
of the more basic phrases because these
are things that i hear i see them in
textbooks but to actually use them you
know live in real meaningful
conversation that's where you start to
pick up on them that's where you start
to to basically it's a it's also an
issue of credibility you have to not
only have seen it in the textbook but to
see people use it and you use it and you
get it wrong and they correct you and
you use it again and that kind of thing
you have to go through but i'm not in
any hurry to do that i'm rather
interested in increasing my vocabulary
and then as i uh you know get into
conversations and take i'll not only
activate my vocabulary but i'll get
better at speaking
so that's kind of where i stand
uh you'll see the interview tomorrow i
want to stress again that for me the
90-day challenge was the purpose was to
generate some momentum in language
learning and learning a specific
language korean and also to develop some
some language learning habits and to
push the korean which i dabbled in
before up to a new level to a level
where i believe i can now
basically go forward to fluency fluency
at an at an intelligent level so that i
can have intelligent conversations i
mean the writing that i submitted to our
exchange that link you'll see i'm
talking about the political situation in
ukraine i'm talking i'm not saying my
dog is is uh brown your cat is white i'm
actually starting to engage in
meaningful conversations making mistakes
uh meaningful you know uh opinions and
and expressing meaningful
ideas using korean so
i'm very happy with what i achieved and
i think we learn and i think the
important thing to remember is we learn
languages for ourselves uh i don't think
it's meaningful to say in three months i
want i want to achieve this level well
in what level in reading level in
listening comprehension level and
speaking
i think
what i think is important to say is i
want to really commit to studying this
language develop developing some good
study habits and if i do that then i
know that i will eventually achieve my
goal and so to that extent i am
extremely satisfied
with what i did on the 90-day challenge
and i've heard from others who have had
the same experience who said steve thank
you very much who found my videos
inspiring that's great and that inspired
them to this effort and basically
language learning as i always say comes
down to
attitude
time with the language and developing
the ability to notice and i think if
those of you who did the 90-day
challenge i am sure that you became more
motivated
more confident therefore your attitude
improved you spent that additional time
and in doing so you probably started to
notice things in the language that you
hadn't noticed before at any rate
uh one more video in this series will be
the interview tomorrow and then the
videos will be less frequent maybe once
or twice a week
bye for now